alors mon avis qu'une référence et
jacques perrin qui est acteur et
producteur producteurs de cinéma et de
télévision vous êtes notamment le
producteur sur france 2 de la 25e heure
qui passe dans la nuit de samedi à
dimanche et qui présente des documents
de grande qualité souvent fort rare ce
qui fait que je vous rends compte de
temps en temps dans un ascenseur de
france 2 parce que vous avez comme moi
enregistré des bandes-annonces jeu on se
dit bonjour bonsoir alors comment
aujourd'hui j'ai la chance de voir un
petit peu plus j'aimerais vous dire
simplement mon admiration parce que je
trouve vous êtes un très bon acteur et
que vous êtes surtout un producteur très
courageux que ce soit au cinéma ou à la
télévision
alors c'est vrai que j'ai envie de vous
dire que vous demandez tout de suite
qu'est ce qui vous pousse à engager
votre argent et peut-être à perdre vos
cheveux qui sont blancs d'oeufs puis
d'ailleurs fort longtemps dans des films
comme ceux de ghost à gabat salon comme
caisse gavras pardon z état de siège
section spéciale ou bien le film d'art
ou de bagdadi qui est là or la vie ou
bien cette série que vous aviez fait la
télévision qui s'appelle les médecins
des hommes ou bien encore ce document
vous avez fait sur la guerre d'algérie
qu'est ce qui vous pousse à tenter à
vous investir dans des films qui sont
courageux souvent politique difficile
j'ai pas l'impression de faire une
carrière de producteur mais que je suis
beaucoup plus disponible devant des
sujets ou des personnes qui se
présentent à moi et un certain moment et
je sens qu'il a fait quelque chose
d'impérieux il faut absolument faire ce
film et quand est impérieux la
conviction vient en même temps et j'ai
l'impression que bien souvent les films
les sujets que je rencontre sur des
sujets qui sont nécessaires qui doivent
être nécessairement illustré à l'écran
et donc comme je suis pas si sûr que le
système le froid naturellement je me dis
que c'est bien non seulement de faire du
cinéma mais d'être motivé puis de savoir
que les films que l'on vrai non pas
qu'il soit à ce point important mais qui
ne sont pas inutiles oui alors là
justement quand on voit que vous avez
produit des films de costa gavras que
vous avez pu le produit par le désert
des tartares qui n'est pas lui un film
politique mais je dirais un film quand
même parce que philosophique avait
conduit philosophie est-ce qu'il ya pas
une intention chez vous non seulement de
distraire le terrain mais aussi de lui
donner matière à réflexion et peut-être
presse de faire passer des messages si
bien sûr mais je ne crois pas non plus
que ce soit dans les films politiques
dits politiques résonance politique que
j'ai pu faire dans des tartares ce que
je me suis toujours refusé c'est de
trouver un genre ou d'avoir des ddd goût
particulier que je cherche des films
pour les illustrer ce qui me plaît
véritablement c'est d'être disponible
est de trouver dans le désert des
tartares le sujet est important mais ce
qui était encore plus important c'est la
transposition jeudi dans l'action
cinématographique donc de réunir des
gens de savoir à partir d'un thème d'un
sujet d'une idée comment fait-on pour
transformer pour ça et pour que ça
devienne un spectacle et la production
la production je considère que c'est pas
simplement mettre réunir des gens si
aussi une mise en scène c'est la mise en
scène de l'entreprise avant que le film
se fasse avant que le metteur en scène
n'intervienne le rôle du producteur il
est important c'est lui qui donne le
souffle et c'est lui oui mais pour vos
cinémas simplement divertir ou est ce
qu'il faut faire à travers ce
divertissement faire passer quelque
chose peut être réveiller des
consciences peut-être bien sûr mais je
me garderai bien de trop déclaration je
crois que c'est une sensibilité qui
s'arrête à certains sujets et bien sûr
que ces sujets portant nous mêmes des
thèmes qui sont d'importance et puis ce
qui est important c'est rudy c'est
d'être suivant les sujets que l'on
rencontre de trouver toutes toutes les
raisons de trouver toutes les
philosophies qui peuvent porter et de
faire en sorte de les traduire mais je
ne crois pas aussi a priori un cinéma
responsable je ne crois pas a priori un
cinéma politique je crois que c'est tout
simplement en fonction mais j'ai
l'impression que les spectateurs ont
toujours une âme d'enfant et que un
espace comme ça s'il y moteur graphique
je trouve que c'est un espace aussi très
humaniste c'est formidable de voir les
spectateurs qui pleure à des valeurs à
des gens qui ne rencontre dans la rue
peut-être kilos qu'elle ne
s'intéresserait pas et au contraire au
cinéma on est pris on même son prochain
il s'agit de trouver puis en plus et
bien d'avoir un rêve qu'est ce que c'est
que le cinéma c'est la projection aussi
d'une illusion d'un rêve est d'avoir
qu'il ya d'avoir un rêve commun partager
avec les spectateurs et qu'on sache que
le spectacle c'est pas le film c'est le
film qu'à partir du moment où il est
révélé par les spectateurs et que les
deux créent le spectacle
donc c'est une communion c'est une belle
chose quand vous tournez dans une série
télévisée des tournées aussi pour la
télévision le château des oliviers c'est
pour le plaisir de tourner ou simplement
pour gagner de l'argent afin de
l'investir justement dans des
productions qui vont vous coûter très
cher ah c'est vrai que pendant très très
longtemps j'ai travailler parce que
effectivement il fallait il fallait
soutenir un petit peu la production pour
le château des oliviers non parce que je
trouve agréable d'être détracteurs de
temps en temps je suis c'est mon métier
et qu'est ce que j'aime bien quand on
parle de l'imaginaire d'illusions qu'est
ce que j'aime bien rêver rêver sur la
réalité d'un plateau et en plus y avait
un réalisateur que j'aime beaucoup qui
est nicolas gasner et c'était vraiment
très très très agréable mais c'est vrai
que sur autant peut se dire la passion
que l'on peut avoir du cinéma elle est
un peu différente pour la télévision
quand on est sur le tournage il n'y a
pas tellement tellement de différencier
des moyens qui sont peut être différent
une rapidité plus grande mais la passion
du comédien est toujours là je crois
mais est ce que en faisant ses deux
métiers acteurs et producteurs vous ne
vous êtes pas contrarier parfois parce
que je sais pas j'ai l'impression que si
on fait des choses à la fois qui nous
passionne dans la journée on n'est pas
contrariée on va de l'une à l'autre avec
une cohérence est toujours la même chose
je parle toujours du cinéma
[Musique]